[Music]
it seems that the division is riding
high once again following the release of
its late patches I'm Dulce and this is
your game spot news updates Cuba softer
said in a statement to pc games end that
the number of daily active players has
returned to what the gamepad at launch
suggesting that the recent patches were
successful in boring people laugh VP of
live operations and Juan del Sur since
the release of patch 1.4 we went back to
the daily active users we had at launch
because people were so impressed she
said that people came back in part
because of you soft commitment to
improving the game even though that
meant delaying its expansions and the
revenue associated with them some
players left the game earlier than what
we thought then we had to make that
tough call do we keep providing them
with extra content or do we stop
everything for a while settle down fix
everything and then once the game is
where it should be then we start
providing more content and this is what
we did and the community was super happy
about it even though they were
disappointed at first that we were to
push back the next dlc releases part of
ubisoft's effort to improve the division
and its dialogue with fans was the
launch of the games public test server
where players can test new features
before their roles out publicly so are
you still playing the division or have
you moved on let me know in the comments
below I'll come find me on Twitter I met
Lucy James games but more on tom
clancy's the division make sure to keep
the game spot
[Music]